a new initiative led by some of
Hollywood's most powerful women is
taking on sexual harassment across the
country the coalition called times up
was announced yesterday it includes more
than 300 prominent women in
entertainment the group vows to fight
what it calls systemic and equality and
injustice in the workplace from
Hollywood to blue-collar workplaces a
legal defense fund will help less
privileged women and men protect
themselves from sexual misconduct CBS
News contributor Jody Kanter is here her
reporting of course for the New York
Times help break the Harvey Weinstein's
story last fall Jody we were just
talking about what a sign of the times
it is when you're the celebrity and the
green room well how the world has
changed since your report came out
October 5th I was just doing my job as
an investigative reporter well what
incredible work you've done and
obviously it's evolved now to this
time's up how did that originate so
after we and others were reported on
these revelations with Harvey Weinstein
but really throughout Hollywood
Hollywood women began organizing
informally they were gathering in each
other's living rooms and what they say
is that they felt the competition
between them that has always existed
melt away somewhat and they shared these
deep personal stories some of which have
not been told publicly and they found so
many common strands and they decided
that together they wanted to use this
window to actually change the business
that they feel in many ways has kind of
betrayed them and this group doesn't
just impact and focus on Hollywood as we
mentioned these are women and men in
various fields and in various different
ethnicities in various income brackets
probably the most interesting and
ambitious part of this effort is that
these top Hollywood women are trying to
reach across the economic divide and say
we have a common experience with low
paid women and we're going to devote
some of our resources and our privilege
to helping you as well which is where
part of the foward story came in and we
were talking about the economic climate
and you mentioned the Legal Defense Fund
as well I mean that's part of this is
helping folks who wouldn't ordinarily be
able to protect themselves right part of
the goal of these wealthy women in
Hollywood is to provide funds for lower
paid women to protect themselves from
harassment by
using leave legal resources that are
really expensive it can be really
expensive to come forward about sexual
harassment in various ways and so
they're hoping to provide some sort of
security and resources for doing that
Jody they want to change the landscape
broadly no one piece of that that's
pretty ambitious is changing the
boardrooms leadership do you think that
this initiative can push more women into
leadership roles well if you can figure
that that power balance the first
question is in Hollywood the role of
agencies in Hollywood has been
problematic in this whole discussion
because as we reported agencies often
knew about Harvey Weinstein and would
send the women into the hotel rooms
anyway and these were their clients
they're supposed to be protecting so
agencies in some ways around the defense
of right now and one thing that this
group is asking for is much more parity
in all sorts of Hollywood leadership
structures including at the agencies and
so part of the question is two years
from now is the leadership of Hollywood
going to look different and we've got
the Golden Globes coming up this Sunday
needless to say you'll be quite
different from past Golden Globes Awards
and there's talk about a lot of women in
solidarity wearing black but there is
some controversy about it as well from
some who say that's not enough well I
think this is just going to be a
fascinating award show to watch with the
very different dynamic than in past
years because you've got a lot of
ingredients here right this is the first
time that Hollywood has really convened
publicly since the Weinstein and the
other revelations you've got the red
carpet which is pretty retro from a
gender point of view women are paraded
down the red carpet they're expected to
look beautiful to smile usually not to
see much etc etc so what Eva Longoria
said to my colleague Kara Buckley in the
paper in the story that was published
yesterday is she said we're not willing
to just be ornaments this year we're not
willing to go out and sell this award
show without asking any of the big
questions about power in Hollywood and
then you've got the question of what
people will actually say when they're
asked about these issues
there is gonna be a lot of black on that
red carpet ISM what I would imagine
we'll be watching it carefully
Jodi Cancer thank you very much
thank you